ferrand
[Musique]
pourquoi tu veux me tourner à droite
n'allez surtout pas tout droit pour
rejoindre et vaut autour du nord
[Musique]
salut moi ça arrive
salut au breite
c'est parti pour dix huit heures de
route
je te préviens arrivée se passera jamais
rien entre nous
[Musique]
quoi ça tombe bien j'ai trouvé quelqu'un
d'autre pour m'emmener salut salut chez
duca bref ça arrive on chantait c'est
typiquement le genre de mec avec qui
j'aurais dû 6e des moments bout des
doigts tellement une bonne
[Musique]
m
bates motel à éviter absolument le
patron ont pour habitude de se déguiser
en sa mère morte et de tuer les clientes
sous la douche étoilé au formulaire mois
pour les distributeurs
elle se dégage est moche next ii
pourquoi l échoppe de brioches m jack m
juillet août
non c'est une capulet manière jamais
tous les plus près cela a du coup ça
dégage annexes bon ok chopra un jeu de
paume wallonie va je sais qu'ils sont là
puisque je vous dis vous ne trouverez
jamais ici si je sais pas ce que j'ai
l'application localiser mes amis donc du
coup attendait bouger pour j'ai trouvé
attendez attendez j'ai pas mal c'est
juste là bas vous êtes sous ses voûtes
autant pour moi c'est pratiquer
pratiquer ces petites applications
ingénieurs m'ont écouté je souhaite une
bonne job merci au revoir
je suis perdue - brett
même tenue pas comme j'arrive pas à
prendre la photo ah pardon week-end tu
me tiens au calme tout vous de faire ce
n'est compliqué
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]